as a boy I dreamt of playing
professional football for my favorite
local team Glasgow Rangers
my dream came true when I spotted by
Scout in the mid-80s and I joined the
youth team here I Brooks
I've got so many great memories
including plane alongside one of
Scotland's football legends choice tea
perhaps one of the most recognized all
the most famous players ever to grace
the field eyebrows hoist making the run
and I'm on my something on remember um
well the one thing that uh keep it going
the one that's never ever change another
role changes a is a competitive soon
sure that wants to once you do the best
and be the best it can Wow home sweet
home
beautiful
there's some fantastic memories and
there's some tragic memories there's no
other club like it anywhere in the world
Wow the terrible memories were coming
through those main doors and being sent
upstairs to the boss's office to be told
that you're no longer part of Rangers
that's a big kick in the bollocks trust
me I got released on the back of an
injury smashed my cartilage and then
they said they keep an eye on me but
that's just a polite [ __ ] off Freddie
that's all
you
do you know what any form of pain that I
experienced here was eradicated when I
want my third Michigan star and had I
not had the upset in football here with
I Brooks I don't think I'd be the chef I
am today when I played
we ate steak and chips pie and beans and
training was basic run till you drop now
that's all change for the better
but football astringent diets can be
bland and most of them have never set
foot in the kitchen which is something
I'd like to change
I'm not Maury Park Rangers training
ground I mean my old friend Alan McCoy's
to see what they're up to
hopefully hasn't put too much weight on
Oh another smellin a looter young white
boy yeah how we do it must wait I've
watched it me versus you given up
telling off lastima show you I have to
be here what's in it
yep we're gonna give up chin and about
what the stuff up
first the warm-up goodbye then I joined
the squad for full-on training session
tied like this one he's seriously get to
understand how much you miss it followed
by three punishing quickfire matches
hey you did workshop you enjoyed that
training over i'm joined ally for an
infamous rangers routine the ice tub
I've got the perfect thing to warm our
frozen cockles a tasty hot lunch for the
lads that should prove healthy food
doesn't need to be bland and boring
right here in the kitchen the Murray
Park here course you know and this man
hey folks and captain the Rangers and
Scotland why was that something in the
kitchen I wish the two cheese's
alright so gonna do the most amazing
chicken dish poached on sauteed chicken
breast
haricot bean salad and bass Meg roasted
fennel we're kicking off with a fennel
cut into quarters smell it aniseed
lovely nice and fresh fragrant season
drizzle with olive oil and balsamic
vinegar you never cook at home you know
okay yeah no a kick its shamed the other
200 degrees 1215 minutes
as it does in your ass chicken breast
free-range high in protein low in fat
just what these players need to keep
them running we're just gonna poach them
there for six minutes out of a bowl of
garlic little bit of thyme rosemary make
the chicken a lot more fragrant or just
trying to make it a bit more exciting
yeah and no sauces no cream no butter
and something you can get up and feel
energized with gonna make a vinaigrette
berry right let's go cake mustard olive
oil balsamic vinegar go easy on the stop
cuz that dehydration even quicker now
for the second half vegan salad beans
packed with protein olives helped us
season and stop soon become a little bit
bland couple of tablespoons of vinegar
this is baby spinach yeah
packed with iron tossed with basil
leaves and a splash of the dressing
check it out and skin side down
I never thought I'd see the day
Scotland's captain and I'm a prolific
goalscorer razors ever gone on in front
of the stone see what you don't have
that sweet one Gardner
yeah don't sweating the chicken around
easier anyone complains about it being
[ __ ] salty I know who to blame
happily we'll stop in there that's gonna
act almost like a bit of a sauce really
crispy skin
yeah nice moist chicken insider drizzle
the roasted fennel with vinaigrette to
serve a handful of spinach salads and
just sit the fennel on top get a nice
even distribution of the beans and the
olives slice the chicken and spoon on
some vinaigrette here we go
X you know they're gonna say they don't
like it well you know
so Ali you can do that again for the
guys I would do that again for the boys
yes good good good good
what you want star jesus christ almighty
huh